okay
um i'm thinking we can get one last game
in
and then call it a call it a night
so let's get one last speedrun game in
10 plus five and we're playing a 1600
which is fine by me let's go
[Music]
we're gonna get 40 points for a win
our rating our rating gain is going to
slow slow up though okay so
we we already know what we're playing
against the sicilian
i recommend this to every beginner
player
either the grand prix attack
or the c3 sicilian
it's been a while since we've played the
aleppin it really has so let's let's go
back to the elephant and see how it
works against the 1600
why am i so obsessed with the elephant
because again
it's a very positionally healthy opening
you are immediately contesting the
center
and when you play through the center you
automatically get
basically points for playing good
fundamentals
e6 okay so now d4
yeah so e6 is a very common response and
d5 so here we have a choice we can go e5
and transpose the game into an advanced
french if you play the french
rather if you play the advance this
makes a lot of sense because
our opponent might not be intentionally
getting the game into a french but for
the purposes of this
of this game we're going to go for the
more traditional aleppin way of playing
which is to take on d5 with the pawn
giving black the choice of what to
recapture with
okay pawn takes
now which type of structure is this
heading toward
those of you who've watched my speeder
and games in my stream know that this is
heading toward what's called an iqp
structure isolated queens pawn
because at some point we're going to
probably take on c5 and black is going
to be left with
an isolated pawn on d5 oh is there any
rush to take on c5 do we need to do that
now
me we do not
and for the time being we can develop
our pieces and oftentimes the rule of
thumb
in such positions
is to wait for black to develop the dark
squared bishop and only then to take on
c5 in order to make black lose a tempo
so let's begin by playing knight f3
then we can play bishop b5 check and
castle
and only when the bishop from f8 moves
then we're going to take on c5
okay so
i like the idea of giving a check and
developing with tempo
in general trades are going to be in
favor of the side that plays against the
iqp
because
you know the more pieces are traded the
weaker the pawn becomes
yeah so i'll talk about b6 after the
game
v6 is not scary i mean
yes he's going to avoid the iqp
structure but it's going to come at the
cost of development
okay and i'll talk about c4 as well so
let's trade
and then let's castle
this is the main line what he's going
for
so white's going to be slightly better
nothing major but it's going to give us
a chance to play
to show some fundamentals okay bishop e7
now the reason black has played this
very well is because he's positioned his
knight so that on d takes c5 you can
take with the knight
but
we still want to take we still want to
get the iqp structure even though it
means we haven't won a tempo
95
i don't really know why 95 is so
impressive 95 black and just castle all
right that's
not nothing nothing crazy there
but there's a point that i repeat a lot
assuming he takes on c5 i don't know
what he's thinking about bishop c5
allows rookie one check which black
certainly does not want to allow
yeah i know a lot of people are
wondering about b6 that's something i'm
going to talk about after the game
now
assuming that black plays knight takes
c5 perhaps you can think about where we
want this bishop to be developed
of the three
feasible squares e3 f4 and g5 all of
which by the way are completely
reasonable ways to develop the bishop
wow he does take with the bishop on c5
okay
i really don't understand this move
um now there's one important detail
ricky one check i i have a feeling that
he's cooked up the move knight e4 in
response rookie one check knight e4
what does white have in that position
without this move
his idea would be very reasonable
not bishop g5
no this is after after rookie one check
94.
after rookie one check knight e4 we can
play queen takes d5
okay so let's make the move on the board
he's also disconnected
rookie one check
now
if knight e4 black loses contact with
the d5 pawn we play queen takes d5
now bear with me here black can play
bishop takes f2 check right
pins pieces protect so we can't take
that bishop
bishop takes f2 looks very strong
so knight e4 queen takes d5 bishop takes
f2 check but keep calculating we move
our king aside to f1
black takes the rook with the bishop
and this is going to happen and then
what do we do in that position
it's gonna be two pieces for a rook yeah
it's gonna be two pieces for a rook
and that's of course very good for us
this is exactly what happened bishop
takes e1 queen takes e4 check
he can play queen e7 it doesn't matter
then we're going to trade queens and
then pick up the bishop and we're going
to have two pieces for a rook
not
crazy hard to calculate right
take the queen
and then of course we want to take the
bishop with the king our knight is
perfectly well positioned on f3 and now
we have two pieces for a rook we have a
material advantage and we should be able
to convert it
what's up man we should be able to
convert it pretty handily
okay
so first order of business well there's
actually two things we need to be
careful about the first is
we have a couple of weak squares in our
position we have
a hole on d3
that the knight can try to get to
the e file is currently under black's
control so not everything is hunky-dory
here we have to be
cautious
what i like is the idea of starting with
either king f2
but what i like even more is preventing
black from going knight c5
by playing bishop e3 now am i not
worried about stepping into the pin
actually no i'm not because if the king
moves away
then we can respond with king f2 getting
out of the pin and defending the bishop
very
concrete right just calculate
and
these types of concrete calculations
always supersede
your general worry like oh i'm walking
into a pin but it's a completely
temporary pin we're going to play king
f2 on the next move
so our our plan of action king f2 knight
b to d2 and then maybe perhaps we can
get our knight to the center with knight
c4 we can get our rook into the game
once we get all of our pieces into the
game
black is going to have a very hard time
holding things together
there is a nice move here knight f6
which would force us to be accurate but
i'm not afraid of it
okay 95
uh
as i always say when you've got how do
you evaluate two pieces for a rook
generally speaking there's one very
important rule of thumb let's trade
which is that the presence of an
additional pair of rooks favors the side
of the two pieces
so if you took the a1 and a8 rooks off
the board white would still be much
better but it would be a little bit less
clear-cut the presence of the rooks
allows us to keep the minor pieces
anchored right we don't have to worry
about the minor pieces getting tangled
up we can use our rook to defend against
uh side to side rook moves
okay so how should we continue thank you
jacqueline for the prime
let's begin by developing our knight i
think that's a pretty reasonable
approach knight d2
and then our bishop is attacked we got
to be careful we cannot move it because
of rookie 2.
knight c4
would allow rook e4 and get into
unpleasantness
so we bring our rook into the game with
rookie one
good stuff
and then we're ready to play knight f3
and chase the rook away from e5
yeah we could have gotten the knight to
d4 in a variety of ways but it seems
as good as any f5 okay great
uh threatening f4
but the move knight f3 comes with tempo
so
we don't have to worry about f4
now knight a3 was also fine i don't
think it really matters
okay rook b5
this is an instructive moment i think a
lot of people would go b3 uh
automatically but
i made this point in the last game the
same thing about luft right when you're
pushing your pawns
and and you're pushing your pawns for a
reason
you want to see the bigger picture right
v3 is not the only way to defend the
b-pawn
and as somebody mentioned i really like
the idea of going b4 to create an anchor
point for the bishop on c5
why not knights you mean knight d4
because knight d4 would blunder
oh my keyboard died one sec knight d4
would blunder the pawn on b2
uh b6
this gets my tactical senses
bubbling because the rook is almost
trapped although i don't see a way to
physically trap it
if our pawn was on a3 we'd be able to go
c4 here
okay so i have a i have a clever move in
mind folks
a4 would trap the rook if it weren't for
rook d5 and immediately you should come
up with a move immediately you should
come up with a move
now some of you might think okay let's
go c4 then but i already talked about it
c4 blunders the b pawn so we go rook d1
we repurpose our rook we guard the d5
square now we're threatening a4 and i
don't think he has a defense against it
simple enough right
oh yeah i guess black has to play f4 and
give up a pawn
but open up the rook's pathway i mean
that's kind of desperation
oh i'm i guess my webcam is stuck
okay we're good
okay
uh kudos to our opponent he sees it but
now we have another pawn to the good
and we're ready to infiltrate
with rook d7 on top of everything else
rook f5
okay we can go bishop g3 can go bishop
e3
it truly does not matter
um bishop g3 maybe g5
yeah we could go i don't like bishop d6
though because that puts the bishop in
the way of the rook
just because the move is a check right
you shouldn't necessarily
uh you shouldn't necessarily be inclined
to play it you know what i like here i
like to move pawn g3
i like the move g3 because it
keeps the bishop solidified
we're defending against g5 that which is
never going to be a problem if he goes
h6 we go h4 that's the typical typical
kind of sequence right
and i know it's a little scary to have
your pieces on the same file like this
but if you think concretely white's
black's only way to kick them away is g5
and if g5 is taken care of then there's
no problems
okay now let's get down to business we
have upon majority on the queen side you
know what that means
that means
we should
the fastest way to win here is to create
a pass pawn and promote it
in how should we do that
well not a4 right a4 is not the good way
to create a pass pawn because even if we
play a5
black just ignores us
what we want to do is go c4 and here
black cannot stop c5
so an easy way to determine which one to
push right is is to just compare where
your extra pawn actually is located
right it's not on the a file it's down
to the default it's the c pawn that's
the pawn you want to push what's the
move now using a little bit of tactics
let's not automatically assume that this
pawn has to be defended
if you think a little bit tactically you
can see
the move c5 is possible here
after black takes we'll have bishop d6
shack with a fork
classic classic stuff that happens when
your bishop is so active
this is uh
simple but but powerful
so a lot of a lot of you are probably
wondering why i haven't put the rook
behind the pawn because i don't need to
my my minor pieces are perfectly capable
of supervising
this pawn
um king g8 is a nice move though
so
there's attempting to move 95 in this
position
which i don't like because after the
rook moves he's going to be threatening
g5
well c6 no c6 rook takes c6 and then if
knight e5 he's got roxy to check
so
now is a perfect time to protect this
pawn with a rook where do we want to do
it from now normally i agree the rule is
rook behind pawns normally that's true
in this particular instance though i
don't think that's strictly necessary i
don't want to give away the d file
i'm really happy with our defile control
let's go rook d5 hopefully the logic
makes sense right i feel like
controlling the d file here is even more
important
than uh putting the rook behind the pawn
there's no rush to push the pawn here we
can gather our pieces we can play the
move h4
which i would really like to do in order
to permanently prevent g5 so that our
knight could move
without having to worry about it thank
you t-market for the prime
another thing we could do is go knight
to d4
so that the rook defends the g5 square
and so g5 is once again not a problem
thank you t market yeah i like knight t4
followed by c6 okay takes we take with
the pawn of course
and i would imagine he's gonna go rook
b7
yeah he's defending well but we're
grinding him down
okay so there comes a point um in the
conversion of these types of end games
where you have to be ready to give away
a couple of pawns at times in order to
promote your passer
and that moment is going to arrive in in
the event of rook b7
there we go
i'm thinking about a tactical move
what am i thinking of
what move am i thinking about here
and you should always check in such
situations whether or not you can't push
the pawn because when you've got minors
on active squares using forks and pins
you're frequently going to be able to
justify pushing the pawn so let's
consider c6 for a second okay well that
looks like it blunders the pawn but look
a little bit further c6 rook takes c6
what do we
have we've got rook d8 check driving the
king out and then 95 and we pick up the
rook
so we can safely go c6 here
now of course black can also give us a
check on b2 and then take the pawn in a2
but our pawn is so close to c7 we do not
give a rat's ass about the pawn on a2
because our pawn is essentially home
free
it's always a judgment call right you
don't want to start giving away so what
often happens is that
you see a way to promote your pawn and
you start pushing it and you start
giving away your other puns what you
have to be careful about
is a situation where your opponent takes
all of your pawns then gives away the
rook
for the passer and then at the end you
get a situation where you've got like
night against four pawns in this case i
have two minor pieces
so
it's not like black is going to be able
to to give away his rook for one of them
c7 is coming
so black can either take the pawn on a2
or go rook c2 in which case we play c7
and black's gonna have to give the rook
up for the pawn and that's just gonna
leave us with a full extra night
come on man
yvonne thank you for being in hypers why
did i go king e3
i don't like going king g1 in these
situations in any of these situations
because it locks the king on the first
rank and it
and it creates potential for ladder maid
and i don't want that okay c7 obviously
here we can play very quickly
and the game is over
in f7
and rook d8
perhaps not the most accurate perhaps we
could have uh finessed this a little bit
and gone rook d7 check and then gotten
the knight around
i don't care we we know that we can win
a full piece let's go for it he says gg
[Music]
oh i'm not able to send chat messages
because i don't have like a full full
account for the speed run
and
resignation
okay
great stuff let's have a quick look-see
and then we'll end for today
um
so
yeah
so we had an elephant we traded
everything was totally fine and totally
natural up until dc uh bishop takes c5
was just bad
when i take c5 i want to come back to
the point about
iqp's
the point i've drilled into your head is
that when you're facing an isolated
queen pawn the crucial thing is to have
as
vast control of the square in front of
the pawn as possible
you want to control the square in front
of it blockade it
and so the move knight d4 comes to mind
but we know you don't have to rush to
put a knight on d4 you are you're
already controlling the square
and you can control it even further by
playing bishop e3
and then getting the knight out to b2
out to d2 so this is the setup i would
adopt here and then when the time is
right you can put a bishop on d4 or a
knight on d4 white is slightly better
okay bishop c5 of course we give a check
now if he had gone back to e7 of the
bishop let's see if people can apply the
lesson
we learned from the one of the first
speedrun games what would you do here
with white
can you propose a nasty little move
that tries to get black to pay for
losing so many moves very good queen e2
we need two stopping black room castling
and if black plays knight e4
uh we can perhaps try to undermine the
knight with c4 or trade it with knight b
to d2 black end up losing a pawn here
knight e4 queen takes d5 and the game is
already essentially over bishop f2 king
f1
how does it stop castling uh because if
black castles
i guess it doesn't physically stop
castling but this would mean black loses
a piece now in such situations you have
to be careful about a move like rookie 8
i know people know what i'm talking
about sometimes this is actually a trap
but not in this case here you just take
the queen
and not only is the rook on the 8 pinned
but even if it wasn't the knight on f3
is protecting your own rook but you've
got to be a little bit careful about
that trap
okay
so knight e4 queen takes d5 bishop f2
king f1 oh what's up uh
kirker right
yeah so we trade queens we take you on
now it's a technically winning position
okay so you want to go to move 20.
oh yeah so the question is why did we go
knight f3 and not knight c4 knight c4 is
totally
fine but
i don't know why i went knight f3 it's
just that i i was aiming for d4 i
thought this was like the
geometrical center of the board
of course knight c4 is also fine i also
feel like the knight
is sort of slowing down the progress of
our own pawns it really doesn't matter
both of those moves would have been
totally acceptable oh and finally
uh the knight would anchor the rook and
you went oh yeah so i forgot what i
forgot to talk about a lot of people
were worried about black going b6
so of course the move b6 avoids the iqp
structure but white's position is also
good just because we've got great
development
so for instance we could go rookie one
check bishop e7 we could still go queen
e2 and bother black stop him from
castling
um
or we could go b6 or key one check
bishop e7 and for example knight e5
which some people suggested
and if black castles then there's knight
c6 and guess what we're making black pay
for the move b6
the move b6 is not all you know all good
because it weakens a lot of these light
squares and at some point later you
could also go queen a4 and try to
infiltrate them so don't worry too much
about your opponent not allowing you to
get into the iqp your position is solid
apart from that too if that makes sense
okay so once we got this end game i
think everything was very
straightforward rook d1 was important
stopping the rook from escaping and
forcing black to give up on other than
that i think it was
pretty simple stuff
um okay guys
i think this is a great spot to end this
is i know this was a shorter stream i
will have a long stream tomorrow i'll
try to find time for five or six hour
stream
um i don't have too much on my uh
docket tomorrow
but for today i'm gonna go take the
friday night off i hope you guys do as
well hope you have a great start to the
weekend i hope you enjoyed the speed run
a little extended speed run today thank
you everybody for the excellent support
you have plenty more entertainment to
look forward to thanks guys for hanging
out have a great start to the week and
i'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you